at the start of the series Special Agent
Mark Benford of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation emerges from his crashed
vehicle and discovers the city of Los
Angeles in turmoil cars have collided
into each other airplanes have crashed
into the nearby buildings and hundreds
of thousands of people have died
following this the series jumps back to
four hours earlier where Mark is at his
house getting ready for work he lives
with his wife Olivia a Doctor by
profession and their six-year-old
daughter Charlie after breakfast Mark
heads outside and greets Nicole
Charlie's babysitter he asks her to stay
late that day because Olivia has to work
a late shift at the hospital Nicole
takes this as the perfect opportunity to
have some alone time so she accepts
meanwhile Olivia tries to call Bryce
Varley a fellow doctor but he doesn't
pick up it turns out that he has not
reported to work in a few days we are
then taken to a pier where Bryce is
casually strolling around as he observes
the nearby people enjoying themselves he
pulls out a handgun from his bag on the
other hand Mark is attending an
alcoholic synonymous meeting where Aaron
Stark a friend of Marx is giving a
speech he describes how his Marine
daughter Tracy died in Afghanistan and
how his wife divorced him when he needed
her the most after the meeting Mark
tells his friend to move on and find a
girl and the latter reluctantly agrees
later Mark joins his partner Dimitri in
surveilling an unnamed woman Dimitri
takes pictures of her as she shakes
hands with her accomplices shortly after
the unidentified woman and her
accomplices get into a black vehicle and
prepare to leave seeing this Mark radios
his boss Stanford weddick and a fellow
FBI agent Janice Hawk to prepare for
mobile surveillance unfortunately the
vehicle's occupants become aware that
they're being pursued and make an effort
to flee Mark and Dimitri immediately go
after the vehicle resulting in a
high-speed chase through the streets of
LA but before the bad guys are caught
suddenly the world goes into a blackout
in this period everyone loses
Consciousness and sees a glimpse of
their future Mark sees that he is alone
and stressed out at night in his office
he writes down who else knows on a page
a day calendar posts stuff on a bulletin
board and drink some alcohol the day is
April 29 2010 according to the calendar
as red laser light pierces the darkness
of Mark's office masked men enter the
room and look for Mark because he knows
too much about the global outage back in
the present everything has been
devastated for two minutes and 17
seconds everyone on Earth went
unconscious the incident has serious
consequences massive vehicle accidents
crashed aircraft blazing fires and even
a kangaroo trotting across downtown Los
Angeles if that kangaroo doesn't kick
some ass later I want my money back but
surprisingly the blackout also saved
some people for instance Bryce who is
having a go at his life was stopped when
he wakes up he interprets the strange
occurrence as a message that his death
was not meant to be with renewed
motivation he then rushes to the
hospital to assist Olivia at the
hospital everyone is left equally
confused by the blackout however they
don't have much time to think about it
as an eight-year-old boy named Dylan
Simcoe is about to undergo a surgery to
remove his brain brain tumor the weird
thing is that Dylan knows Olivia despite
her meeting him for the first time in
the next scene the heroic doctors
somehow managed to save the boy but
learned that his mother died in the
widespread blackout to make matters
worse Olivia and the hospital staff are
unable to find his father elsewhere at
the FBI headquarters Mark and Dimitri
bring in the woman they were chasing
after when the blackout occurred they
tried to interrogate her but the woman
claims that she has nothing to do with
what happened later as all the FBI
agents are in a meeting Mark shares the
specifics of his blackout Vision he
claims to have experienced a flash but
it wasn't from the past but from the
future hence they give it the name Flash
Forward oh [ __ ] they said it hearing
this the other FBI agents also reveal
that they experienced the same
phenomenon it turns out that everyone
had flashes of events that have not yet
occurred it gets weirder here all the
flashes took place on the 29th of April
2010 which is six months from now while
everyone is busy explaining their
flashes Dimitri is concerned because he
did not have one he wonders if that has
been because six months from now he will
be dead on the other hand Janice reveals
that she saw herself 17 weeks pregnant
which is odd because she doesn't even
have a boyfriend maybe it was the
kangaroo then Mark mentions that in his
vision he was investigating the cause of
The Flash Forward hearing this his boss
wedding assigns him Dimitri and Janice
to investigate the case to kick start
their investigation Janice wants to
create a website so people from around
the world can post their Visions this
way they can search for patterns that
are similar and research about them
later in his office Dimitri helps Mark
put together his vision so that they can
get a lead Mark reveals that in his
flash he saw that the name of the
investigation was Mosaic the name d
Gibbons was written on a note card there
were also some photographs one of an old
man and one of a doll that was burned
with a bullet casing nearby the words
blue hand were written on another note
one of them asked men coming to kill him
had a tattoo on his arm three stars Mark
was also wearing a friendship bracelet
like the ones kids make and lastly he
was drinking heavily elsewhere a tired
Olivia wonders what her flash meant she
had seen a man in her house and called
him honey suggesting that she and Mark
had ended their marriage Olivia is upset
because of the strong feelings she had
for the mystery man in her flash she
shares this with mark but instead of
being angry he Comforts her by saying
that just because they saw those things
happen doesn't necessarily mean they're
going to happen meanwhile at the
hospital Dylan's father Lloyd Simcoe
arrives to visit his kid in a shocking
turn of events it is revealed that the
man Olivia saw in her flash is none
other than Lloyd himself back at home
Charlie informs her father that she had
a nightmare the little girl is scared so
Mark doesn't inquire about it but just
then he notices something in her Palm
Charlie says that it is a bracelet of
friendship that she has bought for her
father the bracelet is the same one that
Mark was wearing in his flash realizing
that his flash events are unfolding Mark
becomes overwhelmed but nonetheless he
lets his daughter put the bracelet on
him at the FBI headquarters Janice has
spent the last five hours pouring over
footage from numerous security cameras
and every video depicts the same thing
people all over the globe blacking out
for 2 minutes and 17 seconds however in
one video which was recorded at a sports
event in Detroit the whole stadium crowd
Falls unconscious except for one figure
the person slowly moves along the
stadium until finally Vanishing into the
exit's Shadows he was born into the
darkness the following day at school
Charlie gets into trouble with one of
her classmates when she is forced to
share what she saw in the blackout later
at a staff meeting weda informs the LA
field office employees that six FBI
agents had quit that morning bringing
the three-day total of resignations to
18 as he continues explaining the
situation a woman interrupts him and
mocks his speech she is introduced as
Anastasia Markham Deputy Chief of
Homeland Security just then Mark's phone
ranks and he rushes at the door stating
that there is an issue at his daughter's
school in the next scene Mark meets with
Olivia and principal Bayern at Charlie's
School Bayern is concerned about the
little girl's reluctance to talk about
her vision implying that she saw some
something bad later Mark and Olivia
discussed the matter and speculate that
their daughters saw the man in Olivia's
Vision meanwhile at the FBI field office
Anastasia expresses skepticism regarding
the legitimacy of the investigation she
claims that they're spending too much
time and money on the useless website
but her demeanor quickly changes when
wedix shows her the Detroit Stadium's
security video of the person whom they
refer to as Bane I mean suspect zero
shortly after as Dimitri and Mark are
talking about D Gibbons Janice
interrupts them announcing that a woman
named Dede Gibbons is asking to see
Dimitri wasting no time the FBI agents
are questioning Gibbons when asked about
her flash she describes an angry phone
call about pigeons with an unknown
person during which she screamed at the
person to speak with Mark and Dimitri on
the other hand Olivia brings Charlie to
the hospital with her as she is working
Lloyd approaches her to thank her for
saving his son's life seeing him Olivia
realizes that he is the same man she
called honey in her flash taken aback
she takes her daughter to the room where
Dylan and her father are present a
Olivia then asks Charlie if she
recognizes Lloyd but the little girl
replies that she does not however just
as Olivia breathes a sigh of relief
Charlie notices Dylan and starts
screaming she demands to know who hurt
him indicating that she had seen him in
her flash back at the field office
Janice reports that the only interesting
information she could find on Gibbons
was that her credit card was used twice
within minutes to make purchases in
Virginia and Utah Dimitri believes that
a cloned card was used by someone else
either that or Gibbons was purchasing
some sexy time fun online just then
wetek remembers what Gibbons said
earlier she used the word pigeon a lot
of times in her flash realizing that the
word may be of significant importance
Janice searches for the term and
discovers a place called pigeon in Utah
as the discussion is going on Mark sees
his wife in the hallway and excuses
himself Olivia tells Mark about their
daughter's reaction to seeing Dylan and
about meeting the man she saw in her
flash as expected Mark is devastated to
hear this as his worst fears are
starting to come true he tries to
inquire further but just then and
Dimitri interrupts them with an
important lead it turns out that
gibbons's clone credit card has just
been used to buy a bus ticket out of
pigeon Utah later Mark and Dimitri reach
pigeon to meet with the sheriff Keegan a
local officer the FBI and the pigeon
Sheriff's Department have staked out the
local bus station in the hopes of
catching whoever cloned gibbons's credit
card believing that they are the right d
Gibbons however the bus departs after
dark with no passengers on it much to
the dismay of the group but as they are
about to leave the scene they spot an
abandoned doll factory which Mark
connects with the photograph of the doll
he saw in his flash because of the Clue
the group breaks into the factory and
sees a shadow on the Move unfortunately
while pursuing it Mark sets off a booby
trap and causes some of the hanging
dolls to bounce around soon they enter a
room and find a strange man holding two
lighters surrounded by computer
equipment he drops the lighters and they
erupt in Flames the man then shoots
Sheriff Keegan killing her on the spot
he must have known that we just met that
character and don't care about her very
much Mark and Dimitri fire back but the
mysterious man escapes and releases some
grenades setting off an explosion in the
aftermath of the incident investigators
discover a cell phone and a white queen
chess piece they believe that the
mysterious man is a heavy duty computer
hacker later the FBI agents discovered
that the cell phone discovered at the
doll factory made a phone call during
the blackout the call was made to
someone at the same stadium where
suspect zero was indicating that they
both are connected as Dimitri is leaving
the FBI building he receives an
anonymous phone call from a woman
claiming that in her flash she was in an
intelligence briefing where she learned
that Dimitri will be murdered on March
15 2010. she further tells him that he
will be shot three times before abruptly
ending the call shocked Dimitri tries
calling her back but her number is
unavailable at home mark checks in on
Charlie who is awake she tells him that
she got into trouble in school because
she was afraid of what she saw in her
flash when Mark asks what she saw she
responds D Gibbons is a bad man the next
day FBI agents discovery report about
Rudolph gair a convicted Nazi imprisoned
in kwale Germany who has requested a
meeting with Mark the whole department
is confused why an old man from another
country would ask for Mark and so they
look into his file lo and behold he
turns out to be the same man that Mark
was investigating in his flash because
of this Revelation weddik orders Mark
and Janice to head to Germany and
interrogate Geyer next Dimitri's fiancee
Zoe arrives from Seattle and the two
proceed to a motel while lying in bed
they discuss their visions and future
Dimitri is taken aback when he learns
that Zoe's flash was at their wedding
and that he was allegedly in it with a
heavy heart he lies that he also
witnessed the same event at the hospital
Olivia has lunch with her friend Felicia
where they talk about their husbands and
what they saw in the flash Felicia is
the wife of Stan one of the FBI's top
officers and a good friend of Mark she
claims to have seen a young boy ataf
whom she had never seen before living at
her home and addressing her as Mom
elsewhere Mark and Janice arrive at the
German prison where Geyer is being held
and along with the warden and Geyer's
attorney begin to question him
surprisingly the old man demands that he
be released from prison and allowed to
settle in America with his charges
dropped in exchange for the information
after a lot of deliberation Mark agrees
to the deal as though he has the
authority to do that but only if Gaia
reveals something worthy of his trust
however the old man starts explaining
riddles and useless stories which make
no sense to the detectives at all
enraged Mark gives Guyer one last chance
to be useful and the latter finally
starts describing his flash he says that
he was returning to America and at an
airport he was speaking with a customs
official Jerome Murphy he told Murphy
that he had a murder to thank for his
freedom when Mark asks why he was called
out of all people Gaia reveals that he
was sent to America because of Mark to
confirm Geyer's flash Dimitri meets with
Murphy and inquires if he also saw the
same vision surprisingly Murphy recalls
the exact same events hence confirming
that the old man was actually telling
the truth back in Germany mark promises
guy or his freedom and asks him to
explain everything else that he knows
the old man then reveals that the murder
he witnessed was the slaughter of a
large number of crows outside his prison
window although the information is not
significant he gives Mark a book about
birds to research more about them
meanwhile at a memorial service for
officers killed during the global
blackout Felicia notices ataf sitting in
the front row with a woman shortly after
Zoe pleads with Dimitri to set their
wedding date for the D-Day that is April
29 2010 Demetrius hesitant at first but
when Zoe insists he agrees after
returning to the states Mark speculates
that there could have been other events
in which large numbers of birds died he
and Janice head to the office to look
through news files surprisingly they
discover a report from Somalia in 1991
in which a large number of crows died
while residents also experienced a mass
loss of consciousness eerily similar to
the global blackout the series then
shows a flashback to 1991 in the ganwar
region of Somalia where a young boy is
seen hurting a group of goats moments
later he sees a large number of crows
flocking around him to his surprise all
the crows suddenly drop to the ground in
a panic he quickly runs over the hill to
see his village only to find a large
number of people unconscious on the
ground the episode ends as a large
aircraft in the center of the village
appears to be emitting some form of
smoke subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching